before our parents ended the war
but now it's our turn to fight
Navy bomb and they could wipe out a
whole life well he's pretty bad
[Applause]
ready for this
[Music]
they're B what's plan B
rated pg-13 I loved the first Pacific
Rim in that classic tale of robots and
monsters Matt hold weights in that holds
power I grew up watching the old giant
monster movies from Japan the classics
like ultraman space giants and of course
godzilla I just ate it up
everybody has felt that feeling when
those once this guy through a city
it creates an instant excitement with
the technology we have we have a chance
to make it that much more spectacular no
decorator a mess or go any condiments
kazuto-sama Sakhalin Cara Mata and Marko
instant automatically and of course demo
doctor collected coitus ultimately it's
a world conflict and everyone's put
aside their differences and come
together many you enter this program you
join a family we stand together that's
what makes us strong this is our time
this is our chance to make a difference
now help me save the world Pacific Rim
uprising gives an answer back to those
monsters that we've grown up watching if
they were to attack us what would we
have we have the Eggers the fight
sequences are different than in any
other movie I've ever done you're
plugged in and you're along for the ride
[Music]
amara built scrapper she's committed her
whole life to this Jaeger
there's things about the kaiju that
we've never seen before it's just epic
I can announce that this is the most
action ever done
it's like getting a ticket to the best
books in my seven
[Music]
you
you